[MUSIC PLAYING]
WeDeliver is an on-demand
delivery platform
that enables all of your local
businesses to deliver to you.
It's extremely costly
for a local business
to offer delivery service.
And what we've done is,
we've taken the crowd source
methodology and applied
it towards delivery.
So a local baker, a florist,
a high-end retailer,
a dry cleaner even--
we allow them to now
have the ability to
get you product to you
more convenient and
efficient and really cheap.
It's a really scary process,
because at that moment,
you've got this idea.
You really believe in it.
And it's so easy for someone
to drop that on its head,
by saying, no.
And as entrepreneurs,
we have to be confident
that we want to be told no.
You want to get to no
as fast as you can.
And that was what I did.
I went out and
actually asked them,
would you use this, trying
to get them to say, no.
And in fact, I increased
the level of friction,
to try to get nos.
So that can validate,
is this real.
Are they really saying this?
The answer was
yes, so that's what
we ended up coming up with.
When I look at
role playing, there
are these moments and in gaming
that you get experience points.
And I think, every
startup that I created,
I gained more experience points.
And so I keep leveling up.
And so that's the goal, to
keep leveling up in life.